it's nearly Thanksgiving and many people
are already on the Move AAA expects
nearly 55 million people will travel for
the holiday that's the third highest
number it has ever recorded Chris Van
Cleave is at Reagan National Airport
this morning kicking off what is also
going to be a busy week of holiday
travel for him personally Chris good
morning
well good morning Nate we're going to do
the holiday traveling for everyone we'll
be talking about airports from Chicago
tomorrow and then we'll join you
Wednesday from the road like so many
millions of Americans will be doing one
thing we're noticing throughout this
year is that holiday travel periods tend
to start earlier than they used to and
last longer as people have more flexible
work schedules so several airports
including LAX in Los Angeles told us
they expected yesterday to be one of
their two busiest travel days of the
Thanksgiving holiday and what we're
hearing from airports and Airlines and
the TSA is give yourself some extra time
as people come back to traveling they
may find the airports busier than they
remember lines longer planes packed
we are prepared for this influx and
passengers our partners at TSA are
opening all of their security Lanes to
make sure that folks get through in a
timely manner but again the best thing
that passengers can do is to get here
early and make sure they have plenty of
time to navigate the airport
now drivers can expect traffic to build
as we get closer to Thanksgiving AAA
expects Wednesday to be the busiest
driving day ahead of the holiday and of
course Sunday the day after the Sunday
after Thanksgiving is typically one of
the busiest travel days of the year on
the roads and at the airports kale
all right Chris thank you very much